hello and welcome to this video
international master w sir wat saket
Varla salad from Egypt okay yo we should
be for it's also very reliable line for
black that's a very early 94 yeah I'm
probably not a big deal okay so usually
this transformation is quite good for
white it's only that d3 year and I
wonder about this if I can just go d3
this position is nice for wide but I
don't think the three looks very strange
night therefore i will pick it up I
guess
you five is a threat here winning the
night and what and maybe yet no other
either move or not but this picks up the
night
Queen goes to d4
ok so can also take b7 here I'm kind of
overwhelmed gym so what is what is
easiest here actually maybe like this
trade Queens
g45 I can probably just keep this light
on their forum and see how to convert
this I didn't really have to give this
porn up but it's still still very nice
vago night h5 what's happening g5 is
hanging and Knight f6 also hanging so I
should win another poem ok this is this
is still a defense admittedly ok so
probably this one check
so given up another pawn I have to be a
bit careful them not to give up even
more stuff so winded these six pawn yeah
holy this
so what I can take you can take these
six now and it will take sieve form step
something easy i can go see 5sd five
then though okay let's take it I should
have given up all that material that was
entirely unnecessary running so what to
do
this would be if I can somehow use this
piece for attacking purposes like rook
c5 and bring this over it's probably not
such a bad a DM
mm okay
I'm taking too long
taking too long one minute 11 I really
have to work on is that I check I get
this decision easy technical winning
position after a couple of moves that
I'm not like squandering it away so
easily I mean it's still we should win
but its its work already and it
shouldn't be in time warning
okay let's do 10
check check check threatening a mate ok
check
black resigns it was a pretty awful game
I mean after yet London's blonde at the
night there for nothing I mean this is a
full piece and then somehow i'm getting
so um relaxed that I tend to just play
stupid stuff there's really no need to
give them anything I can take be seven
or whatever and somehow be one that this
can also do Ruby one on something here
takes Bishop defaults the Queen it can
also take everything here I should just
take the material instead of giving head
and and then I underestimated I mean oh
I half hour forgot about this that's
nice yeah I shouldn't play that the twin
small stack yeah but now he's got two
pawns when the structure is so favorable
that it's still a win but I mean that
was necessary I mean not at all check
and he had some fairly easy win because
the coordination is pretty good they can
all fall one by one so I don't think I
really gave him anything for real but it
was just completely unnecessary to make
any kind of yeah give pawns back or
something like that it was completely
uncalled for okay well thanks for
watching